hey it's Matt from code tech and
tutorials adjusting my camera on the fly
here and okay this alright what I want
to talk about here is actually sort of a
difficult subject to address but I feel
like this needs to be addressed so I'm
gonna come out with it
I'm calling this the Joshua fluke
phenomenon
Joshua fluke is a youtuber he okay I
should make it clear that this is not to
bash him in any sort of way I have a lot
of admiration for the guy I've watched
almost I watched pretty much every video
he comes out with and overall I think he
has really good intentions and has a
good guy I like the guy personally I
really like the guy but I just think
there's one thing one main thing that
needs to point it out that my
be hurting some people on their job but
he seems to talk a lot about job hunting
how to find the jobs you want how to
talk to your pay and I just
I can't help but think feel and maybe
he's not very qualified to be giving
these specific details the reason I say
that it's
well it's complicated I've watched a lot
of his videos and sound a lot of times
he's right a lot of times he's dead on
but there are some things and I think it
all kind of goes back to the one main
thing that he's kind of wrong on and I
think maybe the reason he's had some
trouble with jobs and I think if people
absorbed that part of what he's trying
to teach they might have the same
problem so I just kind of want to lay it
out there and maybe I'm right maybe I'm
wrong I have the feeling that I'm right
I'm sort of in the opposite but where
every job I've had
I mean sure I've had a few who does it
weren't the greatest but for the most
part I've had trouble not
it's almost too easy for me to get a job
it's
and for some reason I'm a bit shameful
that I don't know why
we really add up but I guess it's just I
know that some people really struggle
with it and I just never have like since
as soon as I graduated high school
pretty much
and even before that
I've just always had a really good
experience with jobs my problem is yeah
I already know that I'm working for
someone else and I'm doing it
you know there's always experience and
stuff like that that you get from the
job so it's never all bad even if it
doesn't seem all that great you're still
getting Speight experience man this
roads bumpy
it makes brick
main highway
seventy miles per hour that's just like
Pompey has off-road anyway most off the
topic there
that me
so okay the thing that he does that I
think is more harmful
I think he immediately kind of dismisses
people as almost robots there may be a
better way to say this but he seems to
have a very little respect before people
he's talking to I notice when he does
his live interviews he's it's kind of
rude to the person who's talking to you
and of course they're gonna decline him
of course he's not gonna be the best
option they don't people want to hire
people that they like working with
and that's just always true
you don't want to hire someone that
makes you less excited to come into work
so when you find someone that's kind of
bitter and an income antsy and it's like
Oh what about a year from now they don't
know no one freaking knows what's gonna
happen in a year from now no one can
promise you anything and year from now
so a lot of its toxic seems to be upset
about stuff like that so I go what about
here are you gonna hire me so no you're
just gonna throw me to the wind after a
year no they're not saying that it's
it's kind of the whole point of the
contract is to see if you're a fit for
the company and if you are yes you'll
get hired after year but if you're not
you won't it's you know it's not that
complicated of a thing and it doesn't
mean that they don't care about you it's
just they have their priorities their
priorities are aligned with the company
and with the other people at the company
and you know that's just assumed that's
not like an evil thing we
it's a capitalist environment we live in
here and if you're just like shooting
yourself in the foot all the time you're
not gonna do well your business
so yeah you're gonna you're gonna get
rid of people you don't like that's
that's assumed and you're not gonna like
people that are bitter and negative and
always questioning things that are
impossible to answer that just come off
wrong like oh it's only a year from now
you you might just get rid of me there's
nothing I can do about it yeah maybe
it'll even be sooner so I don't know
stop the instant are- be a little more
pleasant to be around
okay good and I think it goes back to
another thing which is
I think Joshua might be missing the
point or the thing this is really a hard
to like combat on someone for because I
don't even know if it's true maybe I'm
completely wrong but I have the feeling
that he doesn't see things from other
people's perspectives very well
because in the end
no one's no one's all that different
we're all approximately the same we are
a lot more closely related than you
think so the feelings are having other
people have them too
nobody particularly likes the job that
you don't like either probably it's you
know it might be a rare case here and
there but the point is
trying to think how to word this without
it sounding too off whatever
the point is you just have to see things
from other perspectives and
you know everyone's a human in the long
run so those people that are deciding to
to fire you after a while or let you go
they're also human they have
approximately same feelings as you
they're just in a different place in
life and chances are if they're deciding
to get rid of you you're coming across
at them
in a way that they don't like and maybe
the feeling's mutual you don't seem
particularly like them either so it's
probably best you go your separate ways
and I want to say at this point that if
any Joshua fans watch or watching I
think what you're doing is probably the
right thing sir like you're doing very
well your YouTube channel and your other
endeavors and it took a while to get
there and you build it up and I think
you deserve all the success you're
getting now but
I think it's also just very important
for other people that might not be able
to replicate your success as easily that
part more inclined to stay at a job for
a long period of time from the security
and to take care of their family and
that sort of thing and the benefits
to be more cordial with people that's
like super important like you don't even
have to be that good at the job if
you're really good with people because
you know people will want to go to
parties with you and yes all these
corporate printed events you're kind of
right they sometimes are cringing but
also everyone there is just a person
trying to enjoy their life too so if
you're not into that and that's fine
but if you are you know just think that
other people aren't that much different
than you
they're just trying to enjoy their lives
too so you know share some compliments
be cool be down-to-earth and even if you
don't necessarily feel that way in the
moment save it for later where you can
vent in the proper place you know you
don't want to express that to the public
it's just like I don't know it's kind of
the same theorists as making social
media posts like you don't want to make
bitter
rayji social media posts even if you
feel that way occasionally you want to
withhold those and you want to have a
little more tact it's really important
to have tact and the way you go about
things so that that's driving
Rajon roads anyway get a little
distracted by the driving
well I've just noticed that a lot of
people really really lack tact in their
speech and it hurts them a lot so all
right I got to get off here and I'll see
you guys the next video take care of
yourselves